الى تونس نظمت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
التونسيه المعارضه وقفه احتجاج في ولايه
بنزرت الشماليه البلاد
في عدد من مدن وولايات البلاد
بمشروعيه الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره
وندى بالاوضاع الاجتماعيه وغلا الاسعار
كما طالبوا باطلاق سراحناب رئيس حركه
النهضه عالريض
وقال احمد نجيب الشابي خلال الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه في بنزرت ان عشره الاف سيخرجون
من اجل اعاده تونس الى مكانتها الطبيعيه
في المنطقه والعالم
ستكونون بالالاف
وبعشرات الالاف في مدينه بنزرت وفي غيرها
من المدن في وفق قريب من اجل الجوده على
الزوج على تونس وعوده تونس الى مكانتها في
المنطقه وفي العالم وخاصه ان تكون الحاضنه
لابنائه
نحضر اليوم هذا الاجتماع
بانتخابات 17 ديسمبر
رايتهم انه اكثر من مهزله فهي زلزال
هز عرش المتسلطين
والمستبدين الذين
خانوا الامانه